ready with some very special gas are
with Alejandro Jen we're here with Robin
lady and Taryn Bronner doctor lady
you're from the st. Louis students
robotics Association tell us a little
bit about what that is yes
you're not the only special guest here
I'm not actually the the guest of honor
here is Archie he is our mascot for our
organization the st. Louis student
robotics Association we are a non-profit
we have been in business since 2016 and
our goal is to make robotics the next
leading youth team sport and so we work
with lots of different robotics
organizations including FIRST Robotics
vex robotics and others and I brought a
student with me today so this is Terry
on Terry on is from sold an high school
and Terry on is also a chess player
robotics and chess playing chess for two
years so I'm not as good as it and and
as for the dream team it's just a
gathered it's a bunch of schools put
together and we all come together in
environment and we meet at made where as
our partner and we volunteer on Sundays
with children to introduce into robots
that's pretty cool I got a bunch of
questions there my first tummy talk
about this guy who the who's Archie so
Archie is kind of our mascot for the
saint-lo student Robotics Association
and we used Archie as a way to introduce
stem to young kids so you know when we
go to a stem night or a stem event or
even here kids want to drive robots they
want to see them they want to drive them
and so this robot is kind of
non-threatening and he's really cute and
he's kind of our mascot the robot on the
screen however right now that robot is
actually a prototype robot that is used
to help with our dream team so as Terry
on said we have a dream team at made at
the new magic house location on Del Mar
really close to here and it's
community team made up of students from
many different school districts public
parochial and home school as well and
those kids are gonna get together and
play the game that you see there so
that's a mini LEGO version scale of the
actual FRC game so Terry on actually has
one of the parts here and tell them what
that part is and what it does um it's
the Power Cell and the first 15 seconds
the game I wrote our robots are not
being controlled and they have
reflective tape that they use to shoot
and they use the Paracels to shoot into
the power ports to score points
so they're basically playing robot
basketball or soccer in a way but you
said for the 15 seconds they're
autonomous mm-hmm that's really really
cool
well tell us a little bit about these
challenges I'm hearing about the
worldwide technology Raceway
what is that so worldwide technology
Raceway is one of our new partners
that's one of our new partners in 2019
and what we do with the raceway is we
have events there so last year at the
Indy race we set up a stem lane and so
you know the racetrack over in Madison
Illinois was recently bought by
worldwide technologies and one of the
purposes of the raceway now is they want
to have a stem influence for kids so
last summer the weekend of the Indy race
we had stem lane with over 12 exhibitors
for robotics teams the Boy Scouts and we
had a stem exhibit that saw over a
thousand kids that weekend it was so
powerful that this year we're going to
be back again and they've doubled our
space and we want to double our
exhibitors as well and have something
for kids STEM related and of all ages so
that's just one of our initiatives so
that race is going to be August 22nd and
23rd that weekend and that's at the
world wide technologies Raceway let's go
how long was it me to prepare for one of
these races well so to prepare for like
an exhibit at stem lane I started
preparing as soon as the other one ended
last year
it takes quite a while another one of
our initiatives is our dream team and
that's kind of really close to our heart
right now we're working a lot with st.
Louis Public School the magic house as
you can see terrianna has this t-shirt
the magic house is one of our partners
we have also great mentors great coaches
and great kids
from all over the place and this dream
team is actually going to compete and so
we are yeah it tells you right there Del
Mar robotics engineers at the magic
house so that's a little bit about our
dream team upcoming in April however
back to kind of the worldwide technology
Raceway as you know in basketball and
some of the other activities we have in
st. Louis they have a Missouri versus
Illinois competition so we have it in
college basketball and so we're gonna do
the same thing this year with robotics
so we're gonna have a robotics
competition with six teams from Missouri
six teams from Illinois we're calling
that the robot Rumble at world wide
technologies Raceway that's on Saturday
April 4th Saturday April 4 that sounds
awesome
yeah guys you should check it out there
have a question for you chess player
ever bought least I know that would be
probably more heavily geared towards
robotics at the moment but tell me what
are the some similarities you've noticed
between the two and a lot of robotics we
have to do a lot of planning ahead of
time and for our strategy for the game
as you would in chess of course and then
you have to be playing several moves
ahead for chess and robotics we have to
plan ahead for things like that for like
brakes and for us to score our points
and stuff as you would with as there's
points in chess for taking each part on
piece well that's awesome that was just
a final way to then how do people get
involved with all of this well as you
saw on the screen we do have a website w
WS LS are a org we have all kinds of
information on there in forms that you
can fill out to be a volunteer or mentor
our dream team meets at made at the
magic house right on Del Mar on Tuesday
and Thursday nights and so we're always
looking for mentors we're always looking
for volunteers but we're also looking
for new kids and so with this being a
community team made up of all kinds of
high school kids from different schools
and communities
we're always looking to add some so we
have lots of opportunities for you to
get involved with our organization and
just visit our website and it will tell
you how well that's sounds awesome you
have the website right there that it's
just so cool really an Archie awesome
well thank you doctor lately it's very
own for joining us here guys let's go
back to chess well I get to drive Archie
for a while
[Music]